are you doing do you know where they are
right now you have any idea where they
are right now I'm Jewish he's not Jewish
I don't know if he is not doesn't matter
this is the US New York City you don't
have aing right to touch that sh this is
a free country you can away your
Palestine flag and say death to the Jews
or America whenever you want but we can
put a sign okay then don't rip that down
you are doing something you're offending
us mother the city leading yeah you are
when you throw that on the floor you're
leader in the city in a minute I'm going
to litter the floor with you you have a
proof so move the on do you have proof
they're not kidnapped no so shut the